this is C botulinum it's a bacterium
that can produce one of the world's most
lethal substances
it lives in lots of places including the
soil pollen dust and also in honey so
why haven't you died from eating this
sweet treat because you're not a baby as
C botulinum grows it produces botulinum
toxin it's the same stuff used in Botox
but Botox has an extremely low dose
compared to infected food in large
amounts the toxin would attack your
nervous system causing the illness known
as botulism which can lead to paralysis
and even death and since C botulinum is
so common in our environment researchers
believe that bees pick it up on their
way to the hive where they produce honey
one study found C botulinum bacteria in
about 8% of honey samples but before you
purge your pantry consider this normally
when we encounter C botulinum like in
honey it's dormant in this sleepy state
it can't produce the toxin even if you
ate it unless of course you are less
than one year old when C botulinum
enters a baby's large intestine it comes
alive because unlike children and adults
babies less than one year old haven't
been eating real solid foods they've
been drinking milk but when babies are
around four to six months old they stop
drinking human milk and they start
eating other foods that they've never
had before as a result their gut
microbes change very abruptly and it's
during this transition period in the
baby's gut that the lethal C botulinum
bacteria are free to grow and produce
the toxin as the toxin enters the baby's
bloodstream it blocks the ability of
motor nerves to release acetylcholine a
chemical messenger that sends nerve
signals to muscles as a result the baby
starts to lose control of muscles and
appears tired and floppy and as more
toxin enters the bloodstream the muscles
that control swallowing and breathing
stop working
fortunately infant botulism is not very
common and infant botulism due to honey
is even rarer fewer than 100 cases occur
in the u.s. each year and while it's
difficult to pinpoint the source of the
bacterium in many cases experts think
that honey accounts for 15% so it's
important that if your infant shows
signs of weakness you take them to be
evaluated by medical professionals
immediately in some cases doctors can
administer an effective antitoxin but it
can take babies weeks or a month to
recover the FDA recommends waiting until
your baby's first birthday to feed them
honey or any products that are filled
with or dipped in honey
[Music]